we need be put check Tony the safest
hands are still our own I'm doing what
has to be done to stop something worse
how long are you gonna play both sides
do you really want to punch your way out
us have you chose the wrong side keep
telling yourself that
hey youtubers is Charlie so new Captain
America footage we finally get to see
black panther take a swipe at cap shield
they're gonna be so many cat jokes after
this movie comes out Black Panther is
such a badass character in the comics
that people always have a real hard time
saying who would win in a fight Captain
America or black panther because cap has
the Super Soldier Serum he has his
vibranium shield he's a military trained
fighter but Black Panther also has the
vibranium weave suit which is almost
impenetrable vibranium claws and he's
physically enhanced by the herbs that he
takes in to help connect him to the
Panther God so on paper you can kind of
see how they're almost the same
character just from different parts of
the world both have vibranium so really
when you're talking about who would win
in a fight it depends on what the
circumstances of the fight are cap is
always gonna have his morals so I feel
like in this situation he's like the
Superman character the person who pulls
his punches Black Panther does not do
that so I think ad is worst Black
Panther is the equal of Captain America
in any situation if cap did not have his
shield he wouldn't last more than a
couple minutes with Black Panther if
Black Panther didn't have his suit
hadn't taken his herbs also he would not
last a couple minutes with Captain
America so it really just depends on one
of them catching the other off-guard
which usually is not the situation
because they've been teammates for so
long in the comics it's just like
Captain America fighting Iron Man
they don't bum-rush each other it's more
like a boxing match where it's like are
we gonna do this are we really gonna do
this
okay let's go I could do this all day I
don't know that they've shown it in
previous trailers but there have been
some images with cap shield with claw
marks in it this is just where those
claw marks come from just in the context
of the movie because this is the first
time we're seeing Black Panther I think
they're only gonna tease some of the
things that he can do like we'll see him
do some really badass stuff in the suit
and he'll be like oh my god who is this
guy cap won't know that much about him
or his abilities so he'll be completely
caught off guard when he sees his shield
is not a complete defense against the
vibranium claws they kind of addressed
this during Avengers age of Ultron
when cap throws his shield and it gets
stuck inside Ultron Ultron did not get
the chance to make a vibranium body but
the only weapon that's going to be
effective against vibranium armor is
another vibranium weapon so you have
black panthers claws gouging the [ __ ]
out of cap shield they have
really said how they're gonna explain
Black Panthers herbal enhancement it's
not gonna be like the Super Soldier
Serum or anything like that the herb
that he eats is sacred it's very rare
but the movie might go some other route
it's really a combination of science and
nature rather than straight-up science
like caps Super Soldier Serum liked
thematically you feel Black Panther is
more connected to nature than say like
Captain America is from the looks of it
what'll happen is is Black Panther will
show up and be a badass first then we'll
learn about the mechanics behind his
abilities and because it's such a big
film they're probably gonna save a lot
of the lore of Wakanda in the history of
black panther for the solo film so quick
intro to the character in civil war he
probably gets fought to a standstill I
don't think they're gonna let him get
his ass kicked they want you to think
the characters a badass so I think at
worst someone will just be able to fight
him to a standstill
you don't really think about it from a
logistical standpoint too often but you
have all these Avengers flying at each
other how do you make half of them look
really badass without making the other
half look really stupid for losing a
fight so easily that's where they have
stuff like this Hawkeye Black Widow
scene where you get the sense that
they're both pulling punches they don't
want to hurt their friend but they also
can't let them take the Winter Soldier
so amove Abul object meets unstoppable
force in speaking of which I know people
always talk about the Hulk trying to
pick up Thor's hammer is a really good
example of that in the comics Black
Panther has been able to severely wound
the Hulk so just to give you an idea of
how hard he's able to punch but let me
know in the comments who do you think
would win in a fight assuming there's no
foul play
Black Panther or Captain America I feel
like Captain America would take the
first fight then Black Panther would
fight dirty cap who does not fight dirty
would lose the second fight and then the
third would wind up in some sort of draw
because Black Panther is an evil in cap
isn't gonna kill someone just expect
them to find creative ways around that
in the movie like someone will stop the
fight before someone actually ends up
winning
it's like Apollo Creed versus Rocky the
Bell stop that fight then after rocky 3
they have the rematch behind closed
doors and they actually answered the
question of who won that fight in the
new Creed movie which is just a nice
Easter Egg for the old Rocky movies so
this is actually good Black Panther
versus Captain America kind of like
Apollo Creed vs. rocky but what's gonna
happen next is there's a couple shows on
break this week so I'll be doing bonus
videos for the flash there is new agents
of shield
post-new agents of shield tomorrow I
know you guys were asking me all about
the Doctor Strange pictures of Benedict
Cumberbatch walking around he even
walked into a comic book store in
Manhattan in full costume to buy Doctor
Strange theöthe comic his so hilarious I
think what I'll do is I'll make that my
first video on Tuesday so new flash new
Doctor Strange new agents of shield
coming if you guys haven't seen it you
can click here to learn all about the
post-credits scenes I think are gonna be
in Captain America Civil War and you can
click here to learn a little bit more
about Black Panthers history in the
comics thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you